[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we have an epic episode for
you today we are gonna be talking about
nanotechnology where we talking about
open-source cybersecurity and just
making sure that technology is moving us
in a positive direction who better to
have than the co-founder of foresight
Institute with us Christine Peterson hi
Alan thanks this is this is gonna be fun
a lot of fun thank you for coming out of
the show I'm enjoying it already we have
like a really we met like what two ish
years ago something around that and ever
since then I've just felt really good
about what Foresight's doing and about
just this your your presence in this
field makes me feel like we're moving it
in the right direction that's great to
hear thank you and there's so much to
talk about about you know making sure
that technology is moving in this really
important positive ethical direction for
Humanity so all right let's start the
stuff cuz you're 30 this is 32 years
with foresight this is not short you
know we've been at this for some time
yeah this is not a short time so Eric
Drexel in you yes that's right yes and
so this is based on the book which we
have an image of the book races and okay
and so as we pull this up you're in a
kind of like give us give us the quick
understanding of like okay we have the
coming era of nanotech we have all these
exponential technologies that are coming
and how do you end up figuring out what
like an organization like foresight that
could help sort of guide the
conversations right we were both at MIT
at the time
and Eric the 4sight co-founder had an
idea he realized that Wow at that time
we were still just in the very early
days of looking at natural molecular
machinery biological molecular machinery
we were just starting to learn how it
works but he had the insight that you
know not only will we be able someday to
modify these biological molecular
machines but in principle you could make
non-biological molecular machinery that
could in principle do manufacturing and
and I guess this this hit him like a ton
of bricks and when he started explaining
it to his friends we were we were
boggled and he was even starting even
though in those early days to look at
the implications and say what will this
mean for Humanity and and we were all we
were we were very very impressed and
kind of stunned by the by the magnitude
of this insight and the amount of
elaboration he did to it so first he
published a number of some technical
work of course but then eventually he
did this more of a accessible book for
the general public because he felt that
the general public deserved to know
what was coming in the longer term yeah
and and that we thought gee this is
going to be a very powerful thing we'd
better start an organization so in the
back of the book it says you know
contact foresight Institute we didn't
have foresight Institute at the time but
we knew that there'd be a big reaction
and we were right there was and there's
so much to talk about regarding just
having this sort of Nant on the scale of
nanometers having just us to be able to
create abundance and solve so many
problems and ok we'll get into we'll get
into that as we keep talking I think you
know and something else that this kind
of inspired besides the foresight
Institute was just for you to also
become a
technology communicator and a more of a
science communicator is that right a
futurist in this sense yes that's right
I think in the very early days Eric
carried that burden alone but this thing
got too big for one person to handle
that role so now of course there I was
perhaps the second one but now there are
quite a few people who are able to bring
these ideas both to the technical
community the research community but
also to policymakers and even to the
general public as as I think they
deserve to know yeah
this is very interesting that you keep
referencing this you know general public
to disseminate the information in ways
that are relatable and fun and engaging
they inspire people to make change in
their life to get ready for this it's
something we care about here so much and
we do across these different disciplines
so I'm really happy that you know that
this happened in 86 and in the 32 years
later we're still really not preparing
ourselves policy wise and conversation
wise well as we'll talk about later
there are so many other even more urgent
topics
yes and that foresight also is grappling
with so I think we'll get there the path
to molecular nanotechnology is Kent is
through chemistry mmm
chemistry is kind of an incremental
science and we can see steady progress
toward molecular nanotechnology but it's
going to continue to be incremental so
it's going to be one of those things
that kind of sneak up on us I think yeah
and actually a lot of things that we
were going to talk about are kind of
sneaking up on us and it's good that
foresight is in preparing us for these
exponential technologies and have these
conversations so you you were teaching
me earlier that you're the mission of
forces to guide technology in a positive
direction that's right if we can
identify
negative applications
that for example people are not aware of
yet and that perhaps need to be
discussed so that we can avoid them we
will bring those up or we also try to
emphasize ok here are the benefits from
the positive applications because people
don't want to hear about the negative
stuff all the time they want to be
inspired by well what can the positive
uses what benefits do they bring to us
and so we spend a lot of time on that
one of our key staff members now is
Allison dudeman and you know one of her
topics is existential hope mm-hmm which
is another way of communicating this
vision of how can we get people excited
about a positive future building a
positive future rather than always
focusing on the downsides of technology
yep yep and so ok so then there's this
sort of there's this need to have full
ranging conversation about the good the
bad the middle of the nuance around the
ethics and how the technology works and
then when we compile all these I guess
we're running simulations about what
happens at the bat what happens with the
good and then we figure out how to
properly guide policy and all this other
work so maybe as we kind of you know get
our way into the first one of our first
topics with open source maybe give us an
example of where foresight has really
taken that on in a field and it will
help to make sure that you know policy
was pushed and guided and communication
was propagated out there's two areas I
would point at one is in the area of
molecular nanotechnology we already have
safety guidelines published on the web
they've been out there for some time I
think they kind of they anticipate
they're there they're ready before we
need them and how often does that happen
yeah yeah so so we're pretty proud of
that
and then also we are and we'll talk
about this later we are looking pretty
seriously at the interaction between
artificial intelligence and governance
issues and how all that plays with
cybersecurity I don't think anyone else
is really looking heavily at that topic
yet
and what we are they what we're doing
there is we're not ready to issue safety
guidelines but what we're doing is we
are convening the experts yes from the
various AI safety organizations we do
this about once a year to explore how
all these things interact and to take
the next step forward towards safety
guidelines yeah that's that's huge I
love your example of just having the
safety guidelines there before we need
them that's what that's the level that
humanity should be at for us to feel
like we're more like adults instead of
children running around just waiting for
the hiccups to happen okay so so when
approximately wasn't that the word open
source kind of came into our
nomenclature well it turns out right now
this year is the 20th anniversary so we
know exactly it was in 1998 and at that
time for those of your viewers who
remember that was when Netscape was
putting their browser out to make it
become free software but there was a lot
of confusion around the term free
software many people would focus only on
the meaning of free that means zero
price yeah and that is not the meaning
that the originators of that term meant
they wanted to focus on freeze and
freedom but but many users were confused
and it was it was hindering the industry
because in order to have an industry you
had they wanted to sell support services
for open source and this cost money and
but if you go to someone and says here's
here's some free software now you have
to pay for service they feel unhappy
they feel confused and maybe even
deliberately misled so we realized you
know although the term free software has
many benefits we need an additional term
when we're dealing with new people that
will communicate what are the benefits
of this that are not based on price
because the benefits fundamentally
aren't based on price they're very
different and then would you say that
then the sort of another part of the
importance of open-source is that it
enables people to take and build on top
and make it better that's right for
those of you or viewers who aren't
programmers there's the kind of code
that you buy from a proprietary provider
like Microsoft and if you give that to a
programmer they can't understand it but
if you can get what they call the source
code underneath then you can modify it
you can change the software and so in
open-source you can get you can always
get that source code always it's
required mm-hmm so that means that you
can always change it you can modify it
you can share it with anyone and not get
in trouble so which means software is
improvable yeah unlike proprietary code
and I'm sure we've all had this
experience where there's you're using
you're using a piece of software and
there's a problem and they just the
company won't fix it and it stays in
there for years
yeah and it's infuriating yeah so then
open source has then sort of enabled us
to augment the different software's that
we use across our lives and open source
now over the last 20 years you said what
has it really how has it shifted society
tectonic lis like what have been the
disruptions
have occurred well it turns out that
most of the internet the underlying
parts of the Internet are open source
and for those of you who are using any
of the Internet of Things
that is basically based on open source
also so to the retail user and I include
myself in that category I'm not a
programmer we tend to see the world
through a little thin layer of
proprietary code but underneath that is
this huge mountain of open source code
that supports the Internet and then that
sort of you know you opening up the box
that is the foundation of the Internet
which is the open source code then all
the websites and online software all of
this is built on top of that and then
people become proprietary in the way
that they build a top yes often in the
the last layer before people like me
interact with with with code there is
there's a layer that makes it all pretty
and somebody's making money off that and
that's fine but underneath that the
reason things work as well as they do
often is due to open source code and
then that's kind of we can call that a
protocol it's like the Internet Protocol
you can think of it that way sure okay
because I'm making calls to receive
information on my computer okay and then
this also is become a new new in terms
of like hyped up this era of open source
in technologies like blockchain that
enable us to be completely decentralized
or or just democratize information and
new transparent ways yeah I think that's
true I think I think the more we switch
to open-source not just in software but
in other areas for example now there's
such a thing as open source law there's
open source medicine open source
architecture
you name it open source now has has gone
beyond software - it's it's just a term
we use to mean it's it's it's a that the
the plans the the way to build something
is known to everyone and is freely
available it's changeable mm-hmm
it's a way as you say I think it's a
it's a the democratization of Technology
I think it's a good term I love that
open sourcing is crucial because it
doesn't democratize it so then if you
have a maybe a country that is emerging
it's an emerging country in emerging
market they can look at open source law
and say that hey these are maybe some of
the laws that we should take in our open
source of medicine or open source
mechanical engineering or Electrical
Engineering yeah right so it's it's a
veil it's freely available they can
change it to customize it to their own
particular needs which is critically
important and the old term of free is
still true they have the freedom and
it's these things are zero price as well
which is also important especially in
the developing world so yeah all these
things are very exciting in the longer
term I'm I'm thrilled to see something
that started with a small group of us
saying you know this name needs changing
and I when I thought of it I thought
well open-source is good enough I didn't
think oh it's the best term I thought
it's good enough it does the job you
know yeah and then just to see it take
off like this and then to expand beyond
software has been so such a thrill for
me yes I get a little tiny thrill every
single time I hear the term open source'
yeah that's a lot that's a lot that's
great yeah that these are the
contributions that we can make and here
that little those little thrills I
figure I can dine out on this one
indefinitely yeah yeah okay so this part
I think this part is really important to
address about open sources maybe we move
into into maybe somebody some cyber
security expert just right on the way
tell us about what you see happening
with the
the economies of data are kind of
shifting towards open-source as in if
you're not open sourcing your your data
about the about who you're about who
your customers are and how if Google
could open source the data with Amazon
and Apple and Facebook that maybe there
could be some insanely positive ways
that we could amplify living so where do
you see these like economies of data
shifting but also the general data
privacy stuff yeah these are what's very
controversial topic right now because of
the privacy issues and then there's an
additional angle which is of course AI
now seems to be more and more based on
what data can you run on that's when a
big advance on under the current
technologies that they're using for AI
it's heavily dependent on the amount of
data and the quality of the data that
you can run these these algorithms on
and the companies aren't don't
necessarily want to share that data with
their competitors yes so so there's
these gigantic bodies of data out there
big companies like Google and and other
companies like Apple and any of the big
companies now have are sitting on these
huge mountains of data that they can run
through their AI algorithms and learn
fascinating things about all of us how
that interacts with privacy I don't know
but but it's there's there's a
tremendous proprietary value to them of
holding on to this data huge so I don't
know how much open sourcing of data
we're going to see especially given the
privacy issues so it's it's a
complicated question yeah I there's
something about this millennial Jen's
ii-era that's coming that makes me feel
like we will have anonymity but also
transparency but also have these
ecosystems open up so we can gain better
insights something seems right about
that but I also feel the whole
proprietary wanting a
well and look what's happening in China
with the increasing surveillance and
social ratings yes they're doing as
assigned by government not not over here
we're where we would assign each other
ratings but over there it comes from
government and they're actually there to
getting better a tighter and tighter
control of their society to us over here
it seems scary they they seem to be ok
with it so far but I think I think in
Western countries that level of
surveillance and control would be very
problematic it's a big clash
geopolitically that's yeah it's number
one in number two and the tides may be
turning in the century so yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah we'll see we'll see what
happens
what's one of the things that we care
about a lot on the show as being a
collaborative bridge across the world
across those hemispheres because if US
and China can learn how to work together
I think we can basically in many ways
guarantee that the earth does not have
catastrophic existential issues I think
it's they can help it's a great goal
it's a it's a goal it's a goal yeah it's
a goal I think so ok so this is kind of
this is good transition to cybersecurity
ok what is the current state of
cybersecurity we've had Romania Polsky
on the show and you got you a foresight
has had a Romanian Polsky in the AI
safety security congregations that you
have yearly as well this is a pretty
intense topic and moment so what is the
state of cybersecurity it's a complete
disaster
it's a mess it's awful we're in terrible
trouble
I I wish I could be more cheerful about
it but whenever we touch on a possible
dark truth that all of our guests you
chuckle and you and you laugh and I you
know don't find these things funny and
is it a nervous laughter it's nervous I
just don't think it's good for any a
young
person that's watching to see adults
laugh it's it's I think it's it's
nervous nervous laughter it's a good
point I think it's it's a fear reaction
yeah it's actually a fear reaction and
but I'm not afraid that's what I'm
saying I'm not afraid and I'm and I'm
willing you know everybody has to you're
not afraid no not at all not not at all
I can't be afraid because if you're
afraid that's that's that's right and I
think the I think the laughter helps us
say alright we're gonna be brave here
because we have no choice yes we do have
a choice we have to be brave Ron because
we have to fight this well then pick up
your weapon right well that's and
exactly so and in fact that's what we're
doing so let's keep talking because I
want to talk about the weapon yeah yeah
so the current state is a mess
and I like how you you know we just had
this little analyzing of this sort of
like laughter you know you act actually
when Roman was on the show the second
time Ron every time Roman would be like
look at this can you tell if this is
real or not and it's a deep fake and I'm
like I can't tell if it's real or not
and and I'm sitting here looking at him
because I'm it's fully sinking into my
body we are so messed up that we're so
messed around that it's so screwed
and so now like you you called that out
Ron called that out it's like I'm
laughing because I have to be brave find
that sometimes cry laugh or cry yeah
yeah yeah so okay so what are our you
know what what it what is the weaponry
that what is the weapon okay we do have
some tools to address this problem
fortunately it's a huge problem but we
have at least two tools one is
blockchain technology which has been
described to me as a technology that has
something like I think this numbers out
of date something like a 4 billion bug
bounty 4 billion dollar bug
on it in other words if you think about
all the Bitcoin in the world which is a
lot of money now even with the downturn
it's a lot yes and it's going up again
if you could if you could hack that
successfully and get that get that money
you would have a huge amount of money
and yet it's so far the fundamental
Bitcoin blockchain technology has not
been broken there have been there have
been break-ins on the edges among around
software that's sort of built on top of
it
but the fundamental blockchain
technology has not been broken yet so
given that kind of bug bounty you can
say wow we're getting some confidence in
blockchain security which is exciting
and let's let's give an example as well
this is this a very good tool that can
be used to counter the issues in
cybersecurity for example if we are
producing a video on the show we are
labeling it with what's going on the
simulation blockchain and it's labeled
as this is an actual proof that this is
what we did so that if someone is trying
to manipulate the show and say that hey
we're featuring a guest in this other
place that looks like the set and it's
completely digitally synthesized that
they can't get away with it mm-hm
yeah that sounds like the kind of thing
that could be done so so blockchain
gives us one piece of hope that it looks
like that code is pretty secure at this
point we're getting more and more more
happy with the quality of that code it
turns out there's another set of code
which which we've got pretty good
confidence in this is a type of a
programming style called object
capabilities
it is very security-conscious
security is baked in from the beginning
it takes it takes a while to learn it's
harder to write because you have to be
you have to look at security at every
stage it's not something where you write
the code fast and dirty see what breaks
and then try to fix it that's not how
this works this this time this is every
single line you write you're thinking
about security so it's a totally
different mindset it's
take some it's gonna take some learning
mm-hmm there is for example there's a
colonel out there called SEL for that
has been demonstrated formally there's a
formal demonstration that this is
secured it this was handled by the
military I think the US military and
also it's survived a Red Team Blue team
type attack so we're getting pretty
pretty confident that object
capabilities can give us security now so
we're still stuck with the problem which
is you know we have this huge
infrastructure of code which is an
insecure and unsecure ball it's not that
there's any way to fix this code it has
to be completely rewritten which is when
you think about the amount of code in
the world to be rewritten it's like you
are kidding me right that's an immense
amount of code but the way we would
handle it is say well let's start with
what's really important let's start with
code that like the internet the internet
for example utilities mm-hmm
air traffic control right you can think
of specific areas that are like these
are these are absolutely critical areas
you'd say let's start with those and you
know gaming maybe we do gaming last you
know does the game do the games work
well it's not a life-and-death matter if
there's a problem in your games so so so
we haven't we have tools we have a
pathway it's now it's a question of
Education which is why four sites
getting involved yeah there's also a
company that is starting to post about
this for those of your viewers who are
more on the technical side you can go to
Agora comm and a geo are a geo Ric comm
and they will be posting the technical
papers and you can dig in for those of
you who are on the technical side but
for site will be more on the education
side the outreach side saying hey
there's a problem there our solution you
know we don't like to just say there's a
problem and there's no solution there's
a problem and here's here's the pathway
forward to fix
the problem yeah that's good crucial and
then the action items that are needed to
solve it well with the tools I just for
some reason I was just envisioning a new
publications that that about our eyes
new research papers that our eyes about
blockchain solving cybersecurity issues
which is envisioning that and I was like
thinking about what would it be like for
a five or a ten year old to be
understanding these concepts and
embodying them with that very fresh
brain with the fresh real estate in
their mind yeah to be able to take in
these really complicated issues at young
ages because then their creativity can
just unleash into the space right later
in life we desperately need that yeah I
would say for new people coming up
learnt taking the brand new programmers
you know the people who are 10 years old
and saying here's a new know before you
learn the old the old way learn this
learn this way learn this secure way and
then I think once they've learned the
secure way they'll look they'll look at
the other way and say you're kidding me
you coded that way and you expected it
to work and be secure how could it
possibly and we'll say well you're right
it can't possibly so I think yeah we
need to start them young with this new
model and get them thinking about
security from day one I love the
solutions that you listen there's
there's also this such a strange sort of
example of you just take the current way
that social media is hosted and I can
basically just take your picture and
your name and write whatever message I
want and just make it look like you
posted it from Twitter or Facebook and
just start circulating that and then
most of the time people won't go to your
profile and go look at it you actually
said it or not and so this is this is a
huge huge issue and then like you said
could it be that we have the security
systems in place to maybe prevent people
from doing that or
we have some sort of a blockchain
infrastructure to make sure that it's
actually you that's doing it or not this
is also so important it is and and of
course social media probably isn't where
we're going to start right we listed
sort of all right where are we going to
start and social media didn't make that
list No
so in aviation somehow we're going to be
going through a dangerous period here
where people aren't going to be able to
trust what they see on their screens
anymore right they you can't now yeah
you really shouldn't yeah you shouldn't
now but it's gonna get worse and worse
as the press the tools get better and
the prices come down for making fake
videos yeah we're just gonna be seeing
those all the time so people need to
learn that skepticism Wow
we have the cameras analytical thing
that just happened you're constantly
being psychometrically analyzed for your
vulnerabilities for your weak spots just
so that you can be pushed into believing
certain things and it is it's very
unfortunate that now that we have to
hold this extreme skepticism with
absolutely everything on social media
because we don't know who's trying to
megalomaniac we manipulate us eat drink
and be merry
tomorrow it's like so sadly just making
me feel like there's no hole but but I I
think there is lots of hope I do too as
long as people like yourself Christine
you know we're working on it we're
working on it but what's the good work
we're all right that's right go to
Forsyth dot org donate to us and we'll
work on it yes so they can enjoy
foresight come come join force I don't
throw enough money at problems they go
away how much counter money there
in the face again okay cybersecurity is
massive good that we got to talk about
that a lot Ron you threw up a cool image
of Christine you are speaking about open
source we had a good image of you there
and then what do we have as the next
image I want to see oh is it the meat
meat this is this is funny yeah right so
so I think now we're gonna talk about
what are the applications of
nanotechnology Yeah right so it turns
out that you know there the term
nanotechnology is used for a lot of
different things the one the meaning
that foresight uses and that we're most
excited about is means atomically
precise manufacturing in other words
being able to build with atomic
precision and the reason we have this
picture up here is one of the most
exciting applications of being able to
build with atomic precision is in the
area of health right we we have these
organic bodies and when we're young and
healthy they work great generally for
most of us but then over time since we
are fundamentally made of meat we all
know what happens to meat over time it
deteriorates and it's not a pretty sight
and that's what happens to human bodies
over time too we uh when we're young
we're usually healthy and strong but
then over time the molecular machinery
of our bodies the biological macro
molecular machinery starts to break in
various ways and and the repair
mechanisms can't keep up or they're not
designed for it and over time our our
meat doesn't function nearly as well
until eventually it's the oh it's over
for us so when you think about well what
if you could get in there with a device
and put those molecules back where they
should be you throw that next one up the
next image because that's exactly what
wait wait go to the next one and go wait
go one more after this there we go there
we go so this is an artist's conception
that was used in Scientific American and
although it's schematic the fundamentals
in terms of the size of the device
our would be correct so this is it this
would be a proposed molecular machine
very complicated molecular machine that
would go in there and at in this picture
what it's doing is it is going after
plaque in the arteries yeah so the goal
would be to remove that plaque we know
it we know that that plaque is a big
problem
Class C is the current state of being
able to handle that and it's just
putting it's just pushing the plaque
against the walls right it's not
clearing it up like this yeah the goal
would be to go in there use a device to
identify the plaque down at the cellular
or even the molecular level and then
basically remove it process it out of
there so and I think someday this will
happen it's a very ambitious goal but I
think it will happen yes to to get there
though we can back up to one of these
earlier pictures okay and these these
are designs they have not been built yet
but this is a cutaway view of a
planetary gear as an example of a
machine part that could be built down at
the molecular scale we also make
planetary gears at the macro scale I
believe we have these in our cars mm-hmm
but this is a a design an example of
what could be done at the molecular
level and if you go to the previous
picture this is another one this is a
fine motion controller designed by I
believe it was would either be it would
probably be Ralph Merkle
or or Eric Drexler at Institute for
molecular manufacturing and this would
control the actual tip that was going in
there so you can see some of the parts
of these machines have been designed
yeah have they been built no this is
this is a this
a proof-of-concept this is the size this
is smaller than a drop of water oh this
is extremely nice I'm smaller than a
drop of water this would be more like
down at the at the level of yeah lots of
the width of a DNA strand perhaps so
it's the width of a DNA strand closer to
that than one size of a cell so so the
point here is this is not what we would
call an artist just to make things at
that scale with chemistry
that's what chemistry does this is this
is chemistry under physical control
chemistry under precise 3d control so
you've got 3d robotic control of
chemical reactions so chemistry and we
understand and you can do the 3d control
now we're getting there on that so it
will happen but when we look at this
picture it's not something that's been
built but it's not just an artist's
conception it's something that has been
where we use the very best modeling
software with all the chemical laws
built into it to model a device so it's
about halfway between just a picture and
somebody's imagination and a physical
device that's working it's an
engineering design okay so we're at the
level of size of a DNA strand and we're
using chemistry and robots that can
manipulate at that level in three
dimension to make this that's the goal
oh that's so cool and then this is able
to do things like send the nanobots and
its medical devices or there's also
we've seen some pretty bad cases of
things like sending them out to cost
ruckus on the planet as well yeah if you
think about military applications
potential military applications you
could imagine some pretty scary ones I
mean if you can heal a body you could
also potentially damage a body so that's
that's one of the scary scenarios that
you're going to come up with and why we
would focus on beneficial applications
and just try to discourage offensive
military use
of any technology as long as all the
countries in the world can agree on that
that would be great
that's that's that's that's the problem
right what about Latvia what about
Latvia they're good they can handle it
we can handle it yeah okay so this seems
like it's not only solving health issues
solving something that I think we want
to touch on is how this solves a
scarcity issues how this provides for
great amounts of abundance
if nanotechnology can be unleashed to
its fullest we can potentially never
have an era of me having something
precluding you or Iran from having
something we can all have that something
right so here's you know there are two
parts to that one is you need the
atomically precise manufacturing because
what that lets you do is take common
materials even dirt rearrange the atoms
and molecules in in common dirt into
products that we need hmm because the
the atoms and molecules you need
generally are there they're just not
Riyadh arranged properly so in principle
it can be done but you realize if all
the designs were patented that would be
a problem so we need the open source
sourcing within it I don't have we've
got to have the tools but the designs of
what you're building in order to be
affordable by say the poorest people
they need to be open-source designs so
that they don't have to pay expensive
licensing fees now if people wealthy
people want to pay for for patented
designs high fashion right that they
want to have the very latest car that is
that is perhaps perfectly designed and
in the latest fashion they can pay for
non open-source plans to build a car but
for your person who is
perhaps very low income and just needs
basic transportation you want to have
some open source designs for a car that
they can build yeah so you need both the
molecular nanotechnology to build things
and the open source plans so that the
designs are affordable so that P
everyone can have the basics in place
this is very important there's so many
things to unpack from that my mind is
like ah which one do I pull from I keep
saying molecular nanotechnology so
that's is this is seems to be very
important because you're you're you're
you're making it evident that the
Atomics the atoms around us even in
simple things like the air dirt they
have what isn't needed for us to make
what we want with the 3d robots that at
that level that if they could just pull
those atoms and assemble really quickly
that thing right then we could have it
yep so that's why it's the molecular
they would assemble the atoms into
molecules and then make the object right
date what you want to do is you want to
assemble products from the molecule up
so that every molecule is in a designed
location yes there are some products
where you don't care like concrete we
don't care whether concrete is has
molecular precision can I ask for
scaling inquiry quick a a nanometer is a
millionth billion it's a billion right
of a meter so okay a micrometer is a
millionth I think okay so a nano is a
billionth of a meter and then it's a
nano meter the size of a molecule I
would say many molecules are that size
yeah bout okay so one molecule is about
one nanometer okay so yes yes yeah the
small molecules versus the big ones yeah
okay cool that's good for sizing
approximation right yes so you're seeing
construction right so but for that when
we looked at that medical device for
that
let's bring
the medical device again run for that
one you want that atomic precision in
order to build that device what the red
blood cells there we go it to build that
device you do want that level of
precision so while we don't need it for
all our products we do need it for some
and that would be an example of one yes
yes okay and then there was another
thing that you were mentioning with that
which is kind of this like sort of
ethical or moral consideration for this
technology being available for lots of
people as quickly as possible so that
way people could unleash their full
creative potential into the world and
have abundance in food water shelter
what they need technology energy rather
than having scarcity or trying to hold
back the technology trying to hold back
with patents and and lawsuits and and
restricted distribution this is all very
important I like how you you're very
clear on that point but then how do you
because you I also want to ask this
question how do you balance the
capitalistic mentality with I'm going to
pour my soul and my resources into this
and accrue lots of teammates and money
to push this out and then all of a
sudden you know someone else from around
the world is just taking this and using
it and not helping us do more rnd and
continue with this pursuit so how do you
how do you balance out the open sourcing
with the capitalism kind of right well
as we as you know and I'm sure your
viewers know what tends to happen is the
early products are expensive as the
first things of anything always are
expensive there's been this huge amount
of R&D that's gone in and so the first
products are expensive and and wealthy
people buy them and that money flows
back into the process to enable the next
one to be a little cheaper and we've as
we've seen with with with cell phones
right all around the world now if they
started out they were big they were
clunky but they and they were also very
expensive it's three thousand only Wall
Street you know people had them
but on only what is it I don't know 20
years later now more and more people
even in the developing world are getting
these things so and and and really by
those old standards these are super
computers and we're carrying them around
in our pockets and we think nothing of
it
20 years is also a pretty big chunk of
time for someone to be connected to like
a brain computer interface and that
enabling them to achieve significantly a
lot in that 20 year sure it's family I
sure so I think and then of course the
question is well how do we get these
open-source designs for products yeah
and I think when it comes to the basics
that people need shelter basic medical
care I think that there's enough
goodwill out there in the world and and
open-source programmers are often not
compensated for their work but they
continue to work anyway
I think we'll see that when people
realize wow you mean you we can enable
people in developing countries to have a
product if we just do this open source
design and and and free it free it up I
think it will happen I think people will
do that I mean I think it will be it
will be rewarding and fun people will
respect you for it
yes I think I think they'll get social
rewards and those are often more
valuable to people than financial
rewards yeah as as a you know I was
thinking about just a child being born
today and then them in you know 10 or 15
years figuring out that they want to
become an open source molecular
nanotechnology that's their profession I
think that would come with a great deal
of you know social happiness and
absolutely that's really cool
ok what I what I guess maybe what's
needed for us to get to the level of
molecular nanotechnology that we could
just assemble out of you know the ground
won't we
this is going to be a long iron deep
it's gonna be expensive it's going to
involve a lot of chemists and a lot of
modeling chemists and model remember
those models we put there
thank you Ron I thought I was feeling
that again there's our 15 minutes oh
very good yes those models that we put
up there it's going to take a great deal
of effort and figuring out what are the
steps between here and there and making
modeling each step and then doing the
chemistry to actually build the devices
at each step yes and modeling out that
pathway it's it's gonna be a long path
and there's two ways to do it if you
throw a lot of money at it you could
just go straight along the path or if
we're going to do it commercially
then each step has to also have a
spin-off product that makes money and
then the money can flow back back in so
if some government or foundation wanted
to throw a really massive amount of
money on it they could just go straight
through and push through otherwise it's
gonna be a very slow process where we're
gonna have to wait for product product
makes money goes back into R&D yes yes
so it depends on whether it's done sort
of in a non profit way or a for-profit
way and then the the chemistry isn't
needed for the molecule to be able to
attach bond to other molecule and form
as you go right so and I wanted to ask
you were talking a little bit about
simulation at the same time is chemistry
the quantum computing era is going to
help with this process of running the
complicated simulations of maybe making
sure that cyber security is is doing
what is that face you know quantum
computing is probably above my paygrade
it's not a topic that I have grappled
with directly I've been assured by my
by my computing friends that we will we
will manage to deal with quantum
computing that we we can still have
computer security we will find ways to
deal with this challenge yeah so that
means that the positive side of greater
computing power and we can look at that
as a positive as a benefit and we can we
can be happy about that so yeah as as
computers in general get more powerful
whether they're quantum computing or not
the modeling gets easier right
modeling used to be much harder now it's
easier every year it gets easier so we
do you throw more compute power at the
modeling software and it just all goes
faster and that makes everything easier
and we were just fortunate enough to
have will zhang from Righetti on the
show talk teaching us about quantum
computing so I wanted to hear at least
your bit on that okay this has been
super profound I've been loving at
nanotech open source cybersecurity
christine's just such a pleasure to talk
to you about all these you know very
scientific and technological really
important topics about driving humanity
forward and doing in a positive way and
foresight Institute foresight or go join
contribute now something that's not for
site related remember not for site
related is dating coaching surprise
yeah yes tell us about your hobby of
dating coaching cuz you and I started
talking about this and it was getting it
was getting exciting and yeah let's yeah
let's unpack okay so about eight years
ago I decided I it was time for me to
find a new life partner I was ready I
was ready to settle down I wanted a life
partner and but no kids no no kids and
and first life partner didn't work well
it was a long partnership and it worked
for a long time yes but you know we live
long enough now that sometimes even even
a good partnership doesn't take chaos
all the way yeah yeah yeah so may I ask
did you it was
a preference to not have children to
focus on other things or what was them I
have to say Forsyte is pretty much all I
could handle it's your child
yeah pretty much yeah yeah yeah yeah so
no I really I go boy I couldn't do both
so so I decided all right time for a
life partner and you know I was dating
and it just wasn't really working very
well so I was I decided all right time
to do some reading here we're using
tinder right no this is pretend I
remember this is before tinder thank God
it was before Tara don't get me so no we
can actually talk about how tender why -
yes but so I ran across a book it's a
great book with a very clickbait title
and it's the kind of type you'd look at
the title you say this is ridiculous the
title was love in 90 days and I thought
what a clickbait title I what it must be
a ridiculous book but I picked it up
right it worked
uh-huh and I opened it up and they were
talking about oxytocin mmm and they were
talking about hormones and you know I
have some biochemistry background and I
thought oh this book actually has some
content uh-huh despite the silly title
it actually has some content and thank
you Ron super here we go we got our
slide up oh really
so I thought well I'll write I'll buy
this book I took it home and I read it
and it talked about the biochemistry
underlying the dating process and the
and the loving and the falling in love
process and how it's different between
men and women and what that means for
dating and how to get your dating to
work better and I thought wow this is
totally different from anything I have
heard before so I said I'll give it a
try and you know how long it took before
I met my husband 90 days 90 days now it
took two more months before he convinced
me that he was the guy but it took 90
days so the book title even turned
to be pretty much correct which is so
weird okay well how do we fall in love
differently as men or women right yeah
so that's what the slide here is about
so in the upper left is oxytocin and
we've all heard about oxytocin have most
people do know I think that it's it's
the it's the bonding hormone it's the
cuddle hormone it makes you feel loved
and that is the hormone as far as we
understand and this is not this is not
final science here you know it's very
hard to test people falling in love we
can't we don't wear continual monitors
to monitor the process of our hormones
going up and down that's such a good
idea it is great it is and someday we'll
do it but on the upper left here is
oxytocin and that is apparently as best
we understand today this is a hormone
that women use to fall in love and that
makes sense and as women have physical
contact with a man the hormone level
goes up having an orgasm gives her a lot
of it so it helps it helps her fall in
love again so so when this all makes
perfect sense and it's how you think it
would it ought to work
I love how multidisciplinary you are
yeah I love that about you so much I'm
so happy that you're do this because
it's a big it's a big you're a role
model for so many other people to not
just latch into one space but to going
oh it's more fun this way
it's much more fun this way so and then
so you would think that it would work
for men too but it doesn't work that way
men like oxytocin and it has an effect
on them but it's not nearly as strong on
the bottom right is vasopressin and as
far as we understand now that's how men
fall in love they need a certain amount
of vasopressin in their bodies for them
to switch for them to switch over from
just interested you know interested to
you know falling in love and actually
wanting to commit so it's it's
this before they get the vasopressin
they're still having testosterone which
means they have a great sex drive so
that's all great they have the lust but
that doesn't mean they have the romantic
love yes
so what pushes them over from from the
original stages of a trip real
attraction but it's just a physical
attraction over to this emotional
attraction this emotional commitment of
romantic love and actually wanting to
make a commitment to one person is
apparently they claim it's vasopressin
and an invest person can we also think
of it as like a love hormone in the well
you know we never thought of it that way
for a long time we thought it would just
had to do with blood pressure and things
like that I mean it has many roles in
the body so we didn't think that it had
this role in fact in the love in 90 days
book they thought it was dopamine a few
years ago they thought it was dopamine
now there's new data we think okay it
seems to be vasopressin for sure
but well one thing we seem pretty clear
on is it's not oxytocin it's different
which means that this actually has an
impact in how the romantic process needs
to go in order for both parties to flip
over from just this initial attraction
to oh my gosh this is the person that I
want to be with and it depends on if the
person desires a romantic process that
follows a standardized sort of like oh
oh I'm looking for the one person that I
want to love for the rest of my life so
then maybe follow this process that and
maybe you're gonna hear about to
describe versus if you're maybe desire
to just be in the playing field right
now then it's different for you you
might want to follow different
strategies or if you want to just date
to not have the outcome like that then
maybe you're different strategy or
polyamory you want to follow different
strategies so yeah so can so give us the
the breakdown of if you want to be in a
relationship with someone long-term
marriage good thing right how would one
can I just say something before you
continue why can't we just love without
having to fall but I think that falling
in love is the lie to say that you know
I fell in love I think that's that's
where the big lie lays you know we can't
be destroyed by right by our
understanding of love where it's all
about who butterflies in my stomach and
lights in my eyes and stars and you know
I just falling in love it's just it's
dangerous love without falling what do
you think I think the reason that so
many people use that term falling in
love the falling part is that when if
and this doesn't happen to everybody
because it I didn't have this kind of
this this kind of reaction until I was
over 40 so and I think that means
probably some people go through their
whole lives and never have this happen
to them but when these hormones do what
Mother Nature sort of wants them to do
to you it's an overwhelming feeling and
it's it's you feel like there's this
huge chemical reactions going on in your
body and it's an it feels like it's an
out of control process and I think that
that's where this falling metaphor comes
from now there is what Ron feels when he
eats sushi it's Ron's favorite famous
quote when you say I love with a person
it's just maybe that's just my path that
was my suggestion to be to be cautious
because of the love I do have in my
heart to love my understanding of love
and how I can love thy neighbor or love
my enemies and I understand that
aspect of love whereas you know
one-on-one loving someone person and
[ __ ] everybody else
let's public displays of affection and
so happy that I have somebody in my life
I'm so strong and it's it's it's it's
it's it's dangerous and and and in a
bunch of [ __ ] so I think I have a good
thing to say maybe here for when Ron
talks about this like falling in love
versus just love what if we could feel
this sort of feeling that you're
describing right now where it's we can
feel this change in our biochemistry
nature hold on hold on I'm just saying
what if we could potentially have that
feeling of the falling in love but what
if we could have that with the ecstasy
of just being alive and taking the
breaths and and that kind of a thing
could that I think there are different
ways to get to the same place I don't
think you have to at least for women as
speaking as a you know I've never been
male so I can only speak for women or
for myself but I have gotten to the same
place in two different ways okay one is
a gradual build-up which is I'm guessing
as oxytocin you know it's just a gradual
buildup of oxytocin that took like
months or years but I've also had the
falling experience too so I know at
least in my case I can do it two ways
and I think it it may be true that men
also can do that I don't know I would be
it would be fun to find out I think they
can yeah yeah definitely so so so so I
think that this model is probably about
the falling model there may be other
pathways but I think what we need is we
need more scientific work on this to
find out for example continuous love
modern woman
when I when I did have this falling
reaction because I have a little
biochemistry background I thought I
could tell that my hormone levels were
going crazy
and I thought why can't I go to the
Stanford love lab right now and get my
blood drawn and then watch the tail off
over time I would be fascinating there
is no Stanford love lab you can't I mean
they'd have to be like 24 hours a day
you'd have to be get over here you know
you just fell in love get over here and
then you'd want to do some baseline work
beforehand so that you could go okay Wow
look at them skyrocketing and then watch
them tail off over time because they do
yes they do tail off so yeah I think
there are multiple pathways I wish
someone someone at Stanford should do
the Stanford love lab I would totally
think they would there's a lot they
probably get a Nobel Prize for we could
even just do a love lab just in general
as entrepreneur as long as people come
in and do the baseline like you said and
right when they're in love they get
another blood test right and then we
watch the tapers out the god set for a
fictitious film maybe a TV series or
something I think it should be starting
around Vargas it would make a great
rom-com thing rom-com for sure okay just
quick on the way out of the dating
coaching give us your you're a little
bit on kind of this like the new culture
that's emerged right so hookup culture
so the problem this the book that I
mentioned explains this and I actually
wrote my own little ebook which I can
send out for free to your to your
readers to your viewers about this and
the problem with hookup culture which
has been going on since the birth
control pill came in in the 60s is that
this very fast advancement to a physical
relationship which happens these days
very quickly means that the woman is
getting lots of oxytocin so she is
moving along very quickly toward a bond
whereas the man it turns out that his
vasopressin level if he has sex very
very early in a relationship
apparently it draw
it actually drops which means it
interferes with him having a bond so she
has an accelerated bond and he has he
thinks she's a very nice person a great
roommate maybe you know a great physical
relationship but he's not feeling a
long-term connection to her not
necessarily so so he's definitely not
thinking of marriage or children
definitely not
so you get a lot of this where she's
angry because she's in love has been in
love for months or years they've been
living together she thought this was
going somewhere but he's he thought it
was a roommate situation he thought it
was a friends with benefit thing and
when she starts talking about the future
he's like I didn't what you know I
didn't sign up for this and so we women
say men won't commit well no they they
won't commit they didn't get the
vasopressin they need to commit so
basically our biochemistry czar set up
for the olden days which means before
the birth control pill was approved in
the 60s when physical relationships took
a lot longer you know like at least a
couple of months at least before they
were consummated with it with a full
sexual relationship it took time and
were we even prior to that or if we're
talking like hundreds or even thousands
of years ago where are we having sex
faster than a couple months or no well
it probably depends first on culture
yeah of course but I think you know the
the the marriage traditions at least in
Christianity which has been around for a
couple thousand years now have been you
know marriage thinking about like
ancient civilizations were they hooking
up fast like well be the first hookup
culture at least and at least from
that's a big debate you know there's a
whole there's a big debate between sex
at dawn and sex at dusk
mm-hmm you've probably heard of sex at
dawn okay sex at dawn said yeah they
were hooking up all the time sex 'ok
dusk says no that's sorry Ron science is
wrong well and what's how did that how
did that come out of that well there's a
popular book
called sex at dawn which many of your
viewers have probably heard of at least
which claimed that early man did a great
deal of very fast and multiple
relationship sexual orientation ships I
haven't read this book but then and this
got a lot of coverage people loved it
they said oh we're like the bonobos it
likes the Benoa like the bonobo sir and
then this other book came out saying and
just tore this one apart and said the
science is totally wrong and it was
called sex at dusk that's funny
yes it is a cute tiger saying this is
just complete nonsense and it's just not
true so interesting so there's still
controversial yeah but I have to say the
site the people I know who know more
science they're on the sex at dusk side
so that's why I never read the other one
interesting even though it's a fun book
and and it has a really pleasurable
theory that we want to believe it would
be fun if they were true as far as I can
tell it's not true so anyway to wrap on
this hookup culture is disturbing the
bonding process and the answer is simple
which is slow things down you know just
it is not necessary to you know the
three date rule forget the three day
rule you know it's more likely at least
three month roll something like that and
that's for the specific people that want
to fall in love for a long-term
relationship as potentially marriage
exactly for those people who want that
this is you know delaying things is a
good pathway for people who don't want
that
that's it's irrelevant the whole things
around but also there's also this kind
of weird thing of like if you wait three
months and they're a bad lover in bed
and then you're like ya know right I
don't buy that here you know well here's
why let's say they are bad and and and
you're in love with them and you end up
marrying them and they're bad what is
what is a better hobby than getting
better right if you want to have a nice
hobby a nice hobby it's hard to teach an
old horse new tricks no it's not in this
area
get through those positions but all
those books and the videos and the sex
toys I'm sure doubles manager they
manage Christine this is so
multidisciplinary I love it okay just a
couple we're gonna wrap it fire through
our ending questions that we like asking
our guests on the show do you think we
are alone in the cosmos you know my
working assumption in terms of just my
day-to-day life is that we are and
that's not based on my own calculations
it's based on you know my expert friends
and what they what they think the stuff
I've read I just add that all up and I
say you know as far as I can tell we
seem to be alone maybe we're in a zoo
right yeah there's a lot of
possibilities but we're not seeing you
know if other civilizations for example
had reached the molecular nanotechnology
stage that and we're building Dyson
spheres we'd be seeing those black
places in the sky and we're not seeing
them as far as I can test for as I know
so this is fears are freaking 80s
technology and yeah but the point is
yeah so if you want to capture all the
energy though that's what you do so I
just I'm not I'm not seeing evidence of
anything out there and if we're in a zoo
then then it's a very it's a it's a
pretty darn they've hidden the bars very
well yeah yeah but so alone yes we
thinking yes far as I could tell if you
go okay and then what about the the
multidimensionality would exist past the
three-dimensional physical existence
what about that are we alone there you
mean like the many universes series or
or even maybe even what exists past us
you know spiritually yes
you know I'm gonna leave that to others
just because it's not something I spend
time on you can tell I'm pretty
practical yeah if it doesn't have a
practical impact on on me or humanity or
the earth I figure I have so many
problems just with that that getting
into multi dimensions and it's it's just
not on my to-do list
maybe someday if I live long enough we
have a wolf to take psilocybin and hit
up Golden Gate Park
that would be such a trip okay how do
you think we're in a simulation well
that's a great question I asked two of
my favorite experts first Brad Templeton
who you might have on some day he's very
very amusing guy he points out that
simulation that word implies that
there's a there's a different reality
that this is not a real world we're in
but this he points out is our is our
reality so rather than use the word
simulation he prefers the word either
artificial world or synthetic world or
perhaps emulated world so I'm gonna go
with the term emulated world okay just
for now and I think he makes a good
point because simulation doesn't does
imply there's a that it's not reality
and we do know this is all real but an
emulated world would also imply that it
is not a reality but not the only
reality yeah yeah there there's there's
other mu we're emulating something else
and then Anders Sandburg also a very
interesting person okay that you might
consider his point was you know does it
really make a difference because how
would we change our behavior and there
are those of us for example those of us
in this room who enjoy thinking about
this and find it an interesting amusing
concept but it doesn't really it
wouldn't affect my day-to-day life to
know that we were we were in an
emulation
I do think that many people probably not
the ones who watch your show would be
very disturbed by this idea that we are
in a simulation or emulation that this
would disturb them it might interfere
with their their own creation stories
that they believe about the world mm-hmm
and so that's why I don't push the idea
too much because I think it could rile
up folks and make them uncomfortable
when and and and what they might I don't
know what they I mean look what they've
already done politically so I'm just
gonna let that alone it's it's are we in
an emulation I saw a round and I say
well let's not talk about it because
they might pull the plug yeah and and
I'm sort of joking but I'm sort of not
joking it's sort of like if there were
an emulation and I were running the
emulation and everybody in the emulation
got all focused on this issue it might
get boring and I might say oh okay this
one's over you know so I was like this
one's over maybe we'll just stick just
lens over
let's keep let's just talk about
nanotechnology and AI and and not worry
too much about the emulation side I
don't want them pulling the plug for you
okay good answer last question come on
hurry up I have to go and kill myself
oh yeah last question is what do you
think is the most beautiful thing in the
what I was looking forward to this one I
think the most beautiful thing in the
world is the healthy human body the
strong healthy human body and both for
its aesthetic value and also because of
what it what it contains what it
represents it's the world's most complex
object
it is the world to me most interesting
object it most of the human beings I
know are good people they have wonderful
values and ethics and morals there
they're basically good folks so just
just and I don't think at the human body
needs to be adorned in in I don't that's
why I whenever I see a tattoo I think oh
you've tattooed the Mona Lisa why did
you do that
you know you don't need to do that you
were beautiful before you know we're all
beautiful not only young people knew how
beautiful they were you know when you
were you know homeostatic capacity with
that ability to just be rocking lis
healthy at a very young age that is so
now when we're young and super healthy
we're only focused on oh I'm not as
beautiful as I could be instead of
realizing how beautiful they already are
if only when we were young we all
realized how beautiful we are already
you know they don't tell us that they
don't know how stupid we are mr. Rogers
doing why can't you lose weight and why
can't you be more like your brother it's
true it's true this has been such an
incredible ride I am so grateful so
let's tell folks where the websites are
yes forces over for site org
there's also existential hope calm those
are the top two and then how if they
want to email me about the book yes I'll
send it free beautiful I don't know how
you want to do that
we can put the link in the bio in the
description of the video let's do that
and then we'll also have a direction as
well for them with that Wow
so multidisciplinary we'll have the
links in the bio for you Christine this
has been such a pleasure talking about
all these incredible exponents
technologies and what's going on in the
world and well how to positively guide
technology and thank you for your work
in this field so much and thank ya I'm
glad you've had fun
I knew I
plenty more of these good conversations
to come and more thank you everyone for
tuning in if you guys had a good time
there's a comment below with your
thoughts tell us about the good the bad
Doug Lee what you're doing around this
sector we just want to build more
community more conversation also go and
create what this content go write blogs
go make cool businesses go in make cool
videos go and execute go and build into
our world thank you Ron our producer
director thank you everyone for tuning
in and we will see you soon
[Music]
you